pamphlet was once handed to me outside
the clinic that said women who have
abortions are more likely to sorry are
more likely to sexually abuse their
children
and women are receiving this information
trying to access healthcare
[Music]
and why did you originally decide to go
into midwifery
i wanted to be a vet for
the majority of my life and i did a lot
of work experience with animals
and my favorite thing about animals was
birth i really enjoyed calving i loved
lambing
and puppies i mean you know who doesn't
love baby animals
um and so i decided well i like birth so
much
i reckon i can probably do it with them
with humans
birth is amazing birth is like
it's unbelievable and it's even more
unbelievable when it's humans like it's
it's it's insane if you've ever been out
of birth or you know
birthed you will um you'll know what i'm
talking about
babies coming into the world it's it's
incredible
i've worked in every single aspect of
midwifery that you know that you can
think of um um
and it was only when the rumblings began
in in ireland and it was only when i
suddenly could see this
this change was hopefully coming that i
just decided
to reevaluate what my role meant to me
and i'm a carer of women and pregnant
people that's what my
midwife means and
and i said right i need to get into
abortion services
that's that's what i need to do because
i think there is
just vulnerability and the isolation
that comes from the way the services are
run at the moment
support needs to be there i still do a
bit of both so i work um
mainly in in abortion services but i
also um
i also still do one day a week then and
to work with my clients who decide to
continue with their pregnancy
um and it's it's a really lovely balance
could you explain to me what abortion is
abortion is
ending an unwanted pregnancy
so i mean it ranges from
it ranges from i have one child already
i don't want another i have two kids
already i i can't afford another i've
three i don't
i hadn't planned for a fourth um sexual
assault
um a planned pregnancy
and then suddenly
life circumstances change and this isn't
going to be possible it's
like you you name it the difficult thing
that i have with it is
i don't think that women and pregnant
people
should need to tell their reason for
women who are living in a place where
abortion is not legal what options do
they have
when we think back to kind of
mid-century and we think about
backstreet abortions and a lot of kind
of that image of
like um a wire hanger is kind of used a
lot and i think it's you know that that
imagery is
particularly strong and quite quite
challenging but
backstreet abortions can be done usually
it would be just getting
medicines from unregulated sources so
online or
um yeah through the internet mainly
or you could travel you could go abroad
and that's what the majority of women do
every single flight they reckon between
ireland and the uk
had somebody traveling for a termination
like since forever
and what what does that do to somebody
just to kind of take off and land in a
different country and be treated by
another country and then fly back home
and you have to pretend it didn't happen
because it's a criminal offence
we think about nowadays clients in
ireland who
have a pregnancy with a fatal
abnormality
so they've been told the likelihood is
is that their baby will not survive when
their baby's born
there is not a provision in the republic
of ireland to help those clients so they
have to get on planes and fly to the uk
to receive health care in ireland there
is this
three-day mandatory wait period that
they put in
they've plucked this figure from the sky
somebody has walked in and just said we
need another little bit of red tape
we need another hoop let's just create
this three day number
so what that means is a client will go
or speak to her
healthcare professional usually her gp
hopefully her gp is pro-choice
because there is this whole thing where
they can object and not provide
healthcare if they wish
and then she decides she wants to have a
termination she discusses this with her
healthcare professional
and her healthcare professional says
right come back to me in three days and
she has to wait 72 hours
and for some clients that will take them
over
the 12-week mark so that means they can
no longer have treatment in ireland
there's so many little things that are
just
infuriating and really upsetting and
they do not belong in the 21st century
and for every single person impacted by
these ridiculous nonsensical
limitations they have on the service
they are mentally and physically going
to be affected
it's so damaging to mental health
physical health
having to do that and you know
what other choice do they have i wonder
what is the three-day
kind of rule there for in their eyes
it's just there is absolutely
zero evidence to support this three-day
wait i guess it's this whole thing as
well you
need more time as if
you know as if we don't think about
what we would do in an unplanned
pregnancy your periods late you think
about it you know you you
you worry and think we assess this every
single day of our lives it's always
something that's on the back of your
mind about how you would manage your
health of course
women and pregnant people will make the
right decision for themselves and of
course when they come to you
this is what they want and you have to
respect that
that is their choice but no you need
three more days
can you recall any cases of women who
have died because of
lack of access to abortion or through
getting an illegal abortion
in 2012 a woman
savita jalapenovar
died and she died because she was 17
weeks pregnant
and she was miscarrying
so the pregnancy was ending but
there was still a heartbeat and she was
becoming septic and we know that sepsis
is one of the greatest killers of of
women and pregnant people
and by i think the second day from when
she attended the hospital she started
asking if she could have a termination
and she was refused and because that was
that was the law and a comment was made
and by one of her healthcare
professionals
and when she was asking for a
termination and a comment was made
stating
this is a catholic country and we don't
do that um
she passed her pregnancy um and then she
went into a coma and then she died at
like one o'clock in the morning
in october in 2012. it was actually the
hospital that i just started working in
i just qualified and i was a
um on my little temporary midwifery
contract and at the time you know
when you heard about it it was shocking
but it wasn't
that shocking not that i didn't think
about it again but you know it's
it's the nature of the job that we do is
that
there are you know things happen and
and she was essentially she was it she
was
she was the reason why women in ireland
can now have terminations
so she changed our constitution
and so we owe everything to her but she
just
she just died from not having basic
reproductive health care
it's so weird to it's so weird like
there's a lot of loss
in in our job as midwives we
as well as the amazing wonderful happy
times
we see a lot of loss and we see a lot of
bereavement sorry
no i'm okay
but even at the time you you just go
through the motions with it
and you you accept it as part of your
job any one of us
could have been savita um
but i think the reason why i'm crying
more is because of the positive impact
that she had
um and like
the rest of the weekend of the
referendum it's actually coming up to
the the three-year mark
i'm sorry it's coming up to the
three-year mark at the moment and
and they're doing now they're having a
consultation that it was written into
the legislation that there needed to be
a three-year review
and that's coming up now and i just
think we need to keep that momentum
going and we need to just make it better
and better and better because
you know there still are clients who are
there as many clients
who who are still being forgotten and
are still being exported and that's it
we're exporting a problem
instead of just identifying and dealing
with it here head-on
sorting it out and just normalizing it
could you um
explain to us what a pro-lifer is
um i prefer to call pro-lifers
anti-choice
because i believe i am pro-life and i am
pro-life
the life of the pregnant person
requesting a termination
um so anti-choice
are the people who do not agree
with abortion they don't agree with
total reproductive health
and i will say that you are absolutely
entitled to your opinion
with anything absolutely but what you
are not entitled to and what i feel very
strongly about
is you are not entitled to stand outside
clinics
and force your opinion on clients who
are seeking reproductive health and
that's where i get very annoyed
but i have friends who are
anti-choice and we get on fine and
i have
it's like somebody coming to me and
trying to change my opinion about
abortion it just isn't going to happen
so i can totally appreciate that
but what i don't think that you are
entitled to do is to force your opinion
and you
it is physically forced to give
misleading information
a pamphlet was once handed to me outside
the clinic that said women who have
abortions are more likely to sorry are
more likely to sexually abuse their
children
and women are receiving this information
trying to access health
you are entitled to your opinion
absolutely
and we need opinions and we need
difference of opinion it's really
healthy to have debate but you cannot
debate somebody else's
or force your opinion on somebody else
trying to access healthcare
that is not right one in six i believe
gps or doctors in ireland who are
providing termination services
have been harassed and abused and
received threatening behavior
and like
pro-life nah
it's not on did you ever have any
reservations about
working in the industry i didn't think
about it twice
no not no
not even a rumbling of it and
it's just i've i've unbelievable job
satisfaction
working in this job because you are
removing someone
from a crisis instantly
like the gratitude and the relief
that you were giving to another human
being it's it's incredible no i've never
even had a second thought in it you all
know somebody who's had an abortion
you probably know several people who've
had an abortion
one in four of us have had an abortion
and abortions will continue to happen
at that rate whether or not they are
legal
and regulated and local they will still
occur
but in more dangerous sort of
circumstances and i think we all have a
responsibility
to make this just a really normal part
of our health care it is safe
and it is normal and it is everywhere
i remember the senior investigating
officer from the metropolitan police new
scotland yard
he got hold of me and he said we reckon
there's probably about
30 victims oh and no
i said 500 victims i said that's
probably what it's more like and i've
been investigating savile now for a year